var
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Bir Ormanda yol ikiye ayrıldı ve ben
daha az geçirmiş O andan gitti ve bütün
farkı yaratan bu oldu işlediği ve etmiş
abros ben de bu konuşmamda çıktım yolda
yürümenin gerektirdikleri ni farkı
yaratan etkenleri karşılaştığım
seçenekleri ve aldım kararları sizlere
aktarmaya çalışacağım Herkese merhabalar
ben Markus açar öğrenciyim Mardin'de
doğdum ve büyüdüm
İnsanların hayatında olumlu bir şekilde
dokunmak dünyayı daha yaşanabilir bir
yer haline getirmeye çalışan bir gencim
sizlere kendimi uzun uzadıya tanıtmak
istemem ama marku su Markus yapan üç
temeli sizlerle Ben bilirim Bunlar
sınırsızlık merak ve düşünmek pek
sınırlarla tanıştığım andan itibaren
sınırları hep reddeden bir çocuk oldum
şu küçüklüğümden beri başımı her yukarı
kaldırın da bütün sonsuzluğu yla uçsuz
bucaksız Göz kırpan bir Evren varken ben
aşağıda Hep birileri tarafından çizilmiş
sınırlara sahip bir çerçevenin içerisine
Hayalimdeki tabloyu silemezdim içinde
olmak istediğim tablo bir çerçeve
sığmayacak kadar büyük bütün renkleriyle
coşkulu ve heyecan doluydu her ne kadar
bu çerçeveleri aşabilmek çok kolay
olmasa da biliyordum ki benim
hayatımdaki sınır çizgileri çok ötesinde
bir yerlerde hayallerim vardı Ne
Mardin'in sınırın e Okul müfredatı
sınırı ne de hepimizin sürekli duyduğu
bu hayalden vazgeç yapamazsın gibi
psikolojik sınırlar Ya ben bunların
hiçbirini tanımadım madde engellerle mi
karşılaştım madde engelleri çözmek
aileme yardımcı olmak Hatta yabancı
dilini geliştirmek için Antalya'da
yazları otellerde çalıştım
istediğim Fazla yakın zamanda sadece
okuldaki başarımın yeterli olmadığını
anladım da 10. sınıf öğrencisiydim
onuncu sınıfta okulu Mardin Fen Lisesi
tarafından ulusal bilim kampı proje
yarışması duyurusu yapılmıştı
ben bu yarışmada teorideki Bilge'nin mi
pratiğe dökme fırsatı yakalayabilir dim
Bu yarışmaya katılmaya karar verdiğimde
Belki de daha önce onlarca başarısı olan
okullarla bir yarışa girmiş oldum ancak
bir arkadaşımla beraber geliştirdiğiniz
akıl şehir projesi ile beraber burada
bir başarı elde ettikten sonra bugün
projelere katılma isteği Mart
tıbbi ancak eğitim sisteminde bir
parçası olan üniversite sınavı nedeniyle
Ben bir karar vermem gerekiyordu
tamamen sınav odaklı müfre bu
giden bir öğrenci profilinin içecektim
yoksa projelerle dolu olan Yolumuz
geçecektim
şimbil diyordum ki okulda ne kadar
başarılı olursam olayım bir insana
karşılıksız gülümsediğim de ve onun
mutlu oluşuyla Ruhumda oluşan hazı
hiçbir şey bana veremezdi
Belki de müfredat dışına çıkmak için geç
kalınmış bir yaştayım ancak Bak İçimde
Müthiş derecede topluma hizmet etme
İsteği vardı Bizi biz yapan topluma yap
sağladığımız katkı olmalıydı
akıllı en çok kucağına soru şuydu benim
nasıl katkım olabilir aileme çocuklara
gençlere bilime teknolojiye Dünya nasıl
katkı sağlayabilirim çiğnemiş olduğum
bütün kuralların bütün sınır tanımazlık
ların sorumlusu içinde durduramadım bu
tutkudur
Böylece fikirlerin uygulamaya geçmesinde
önemli bir yere sahip olan proje Allah
bu yolu seçtim Bu yola çıkarken
başarısızlıklar da zorluklarda olacaktır
ancak pes etmemek hedeflerimizi
gerçekleştirebilmek için
kullanabileceğimiz en iyi kabiliyetimiz
olmalı
başarısızlığa uğradığında yeniden
başlayabilecek gücü bula bilmeliyiz bir
Japon atasözünde bir türlü üzere Yedi
kere düşmüş ama 8 kere kalk
merak olmadan sınırlarının varlığını
bile Anlamak mümkün olmayabilir
yaratıcılığı yeni seviyelere çıkarmak
için çocuksu merakımız da tekrar temasa
geçmeniz gerekiyor
gözlemlemek sorular sormak ve tekrar
bilmi bilinmeyene doğru yola çıkmaktan
bahsediyorum onuncu sınıfta ki bu
etkinlikten sonra ben etkinliklere
katılmaya devam ettim aslında
küçüklüğümden beri bilinmeyi teknolojide
bir bam olduğunu söyleyebilirim ancak
döngü şöyle başlıyor beni genel olarak
bilim ve teknolojik araştırmalar
yönlendiren babam olmuştur bu Şöyle ki
ben ortaokuldan mezun olup Mardin Fen
Lisesi'ni kazanınca babam bana birkaç
bilim içerikli kitap hediye etmişti o
zamanlar en çok ilgimi çeken Stephen
Hawking in zamanın kısa tarihi adlı
kitabıydı Bu kitabı çoğu defa okudum ama
çoğu defa okumama rağmen anlayamadığım
için Sanırım daha çok ilgimi çekti merak
ettim ve peşinden gittim Babam bu
kitapları aldıktan dört yıl sonra ise
biz bir takım olarak son tarafından
yapılan bir parçacık fiziği yarışmasında
Uluslararası bir derece elde ettik bu
başarımı anlatmak için babamla sohbete
girdiğimde diyaloğa girdiğim de şu
sözleri kullanmıştım babanın kısaltıcı
diye bağ demiştim Hatırlarsan dedim bana
8. sınıfın Yazın da birkaç kitap
almıştım benim içerikli evet dedi
babacığım galiba aldım O kitaplar
sayesinde Biz bugün sende Finale kaldık
deyip devam ettim teşekkür etti Teşekkür
etmiştim bu ve Evet baba şu an Emin ol
daha iyi anlayabiliyorum kitapları
Bıdı dünya pozitif bir şekilde etmek
isteyen Markus ortak halleri bulunan
Arkadaşlarıyla beraber yeni ekipler
kurdu girişimlerde bulundular sadece
okul müfredatı sınavlarında
ilerleyemezsin Evet okulda
öğrendiklerimizin çoğu Şimdi de
gelecekte de karşımıza çıkacak ve
kullanmamız gerekecekti ancak bunların
sadece kağıtta kalmaması gerekiyordu
keza bu deneyim projeler de aynı şekilde
ilerlemeli sür tarafından yapılan
yarışmaya katıldım da ben sadece al
parçacıkları bozonları veya fema
diyagramlarını öğrenmedim Ben bir takımı
bir hedefe ulaştırmak için motive etmeyi
başkalarıyla iletişime geçmeyi ne tür
kurma yeriz kalmayı ve ortak hataya imza
atmayı öğrendim
Arkadaşlarınla beraber teknoloji
etkinliklerinde bulundukça Ben şunu fark
ettim teknolojileri çiçeği olmayı
seviyorum ve sadece bir ha Evet şimdi
değil bi daim peşindeyim
biliyordum ki şu ana kadar Evet bazı
başarılar elde ettim ama bunların hepsi
benim için bir başlangıç
hatalarından öğrendiklerim başarılardan
denir deneyim dediklerim ile üniversite
hayatım ve sonrasında çalışmalarıma
devam etmem gerekiyordu
bunlar için bilgisayar bilimleri
alanında okumaya yabancı değil mi
geliştirmeye farklı kültürleri tanımaya
ne Türk'ün genişletmek adına kanadı da
okumaya karar verdim Şu an Kanada'da
bulunan mcmaster Üniversitesi'nde
Bilgisayar bilimleri öğrencisiyim karar
verirken ne istediğinizden Emin olmamız
gerektiği ve bunlar için çok çalışmamız
gerekiyor Evet
gece uyurken düşündüğünüz fikirleri
sabahleyin kahvemizi Yudum'dan yudumladı
mızda Yüzde 0,0 birlik bir olanlar da
olsa uygulamaya geçirmeliyiz Ben yurt
dışında okumaya karar verdim de bu
Sadece fikir olarak kalamazdı hemen
araştırmaya başladım ve emin olun bazen
O sizin kovalama mız gerekebiliyor Ben
Kanada başvurusunu yapmak için portala
girdiğimde Türkiye'den birçok lisenin
adını listede görmüştüm ancak Muhtemelen
kendi okulundan lisans seviyesinde bir
başvuru olmadığı için kendi okulun adını
görememiştim mesela biraz uğraş ile
Kendi okulunda ekleyip başvuruya devam
etmiştim
şimdi birçoğumuzun birçok konuda
potansiyeli yeteneği var ama nasıl
başlamak gerektiği konusunda her zaman
durakladığı bir nokta oluyor tabi benim
yurtdışı başvurusu Yurtdışı Eğitim
başvurusu yaparken duraklama mı gibi
başvuru süreci nasıl yürüdü hakkında
fikrim yoktu mülakat içeri sınav içeriği
ülkenin kültürü aksanı iklimi merak
ettiğim bir çok şey vardı işte o noktada
Bulunduğunuz yer için kendisi
değerlendirin motivasyonlarını neler ne
öğrenmek istersiniz fırsatlarımız neler
Şu an için en iyi eşleşme ye karar verin
ve daha sonra geçiş yapmak için kapıyı
açık tutun o anlarımızı Aşık olmayın ve
gerektiğinde esnek ve oraya Bilin ben
bir uzman değilim bir öğrencim ama benim
için nasıl işe yaradığını Biliyorum ve
sizlere bunu aktarmaya çalışıyorum
hayatımızın değişmesi için doğru
insanlarla tanışmak dünyada iz bırakacak
fikirlerin oluşmasındaki en önemli
etkenlerden biridir
Ben projemizin hayata geçmesi
çalışmanızı sürdürebilir olması ve bilgi
birikiminin sağlanması için ilgili
kişilerle iletişime geçmek zorundayım
Sanırım ben bunu yapmak için çoğu zaman
kişileri kovaladım gerekirse mail
yoluyla gerekirse yüz yüze gerekirse
sosyal medya üzerinden bilgi almaya
fikirleri tartışma gibi gereken biri
varsa eğer zaman ulaşmaya çalıştım
ulaşmaya çalıştım kişiler dev
şirketlerin su yolları emanet ve Harvard
daha çalışan akademisyenler başka bir
okulda okuyan projesi öğrenci veya nasıl
çalışan bir insan o
ulaşılamayacak gibi görünen kişilere
ulaşabilirsiniz arkadaşlar internetin
olduğu bir çağdayız ve doğru bir
araştırma ile internet üzerinden birçok
kaynağa erişmek mümkün sadece
araştırma
arama motorundan aramanız gerekli ve
yeterli değil başka metotlarla da
aramayı
gerçekleştirebilirsiniz
ben emaneti de çalışan bilim insanı
tansudan ve ilk kez iletişime geçtiğimde
Tansu Hoca ile beraber Mete atatüre
önünde bulunacağı bir bilim Kongresi
düzenleyebiliriz Mardin'de diye
konuşmayı başlat Mıştım sonraki
dönemlerde Tansu Hoca ile beraber uzay
teknolojileri ve astrofizik bilgilerine
dayalı girişimlerimiz için buluştuk
ondan konferanslar düzenledik bilgi
alışverişi fikir alışverişlerinde
bulunduk ve ile şimdi şu ana kadar devam
etti
projemiz ortaya çıkarırken her çok
sorulan sorular Price sorular şunlardı
12 aklımıza nasıl geldi Nasıl bir yol
izlediniz Özellikle bu sorular sayısal
tabanlı projeler de karşımıza çıkıyordu
şunu söylemeliyim ki 21. yüzyılda
etkinliklerinden olan eleştirel ve
Analitik düşünme burada devreye giriyor
Yahu nedir bu düşünme stilleri derseniz
eleştirel düşünme projeleri yönetme
sorunları çözme ve etkili kanallar
kurmak olarak tanımlanıyor
yani Yetkin Bir liderin düşünmesi
diyebiliriz günümüz dünyasında Gerçekten
düşünme becerisini öğreniyoruz ya da
öğretiyoruz eğitim sistemi aşırı
uzmanlaşmayı takıntı haline getirmeli
eleştirel zekayı teşvik etmelidir
öğrenciler modern dünyayı analiz etmek
için gereken araçlara sahip değil Ne
hakkında düşünmemiz gerektiği
üretilmeden önce nasıl düşüneceğinizi
öğrenmeliyiz
analoji kullanımı yoluyla insanlar
birçok yenilikçi fikir ve benzerlikler
ile sorunlara çözümler üretmiştir size
şunu anlatma bu durum 16 yüzyılın
sonlarında yirmi beş yaşına geldiğinde
capır Güneş'in yörüngesinde dönen
Kopernik gezegen modelini kabul etmişti
ve sonrasında başka bir soru sordu
güneşten ne uzaktaki Gezegenler neden
daha yavaş hareket ediyor caper önceki
düşüncenin sınırların o kadar dışındaydı
ki kullanabileceği hiçbir kanıt yoktu
oldu dolayısıyla analojiler kullanmak
zorundaydı Tıpkı Eda'nın Einstein'ın
genel Görelilik teorisini anlatmak için
bir masa örtüsü ve birkaç meyve
kullanması gibi ben şimdi ve gelecekte
konulara bu perspektifte yaklaşmamız ID
ettiğini düşünüyorum
sürekli olarak hızla değişen taleplere
karşı karşıya Olduğumuz bu dünyada yeni
şeyler denemekten korkmayan geniş
düşünen ve multidisipliner çalışan
ihtiyaç insanlara ihtiyacımız var Evet
21. yüzyılın Leonardo Da öncülerinden
bahsediyorum
Ama bunlar Leonardo Da Vinci gibi olmak
için ise patik alanın önemi çok büyük
herminia Eee Baran'ın belirti üzeri kim
olduğunuzu teoride değil pratikte
öğreniyoruz patik alan için ise
seçtiğimiz Yollarında önemi büyük a
seçilen Yollar Çetin dar ve Zorlu
olabilir ama aynı zamanda
öğrenin yargılarından çok olduğu beyni
şapkadan tavşan çıkarma numarasını yaptı
ve farkı yaratan aydınlanmayı sağlayan
yollardır bir hem sınırlan dışına çıkmak
hem merak ettiklerinizi yanıtını bulmak
hem de yaratıcı düşünmek için yola çıkın
ve devam etsin beni dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]